hi i'm shannon from khan academy and i
want to show you how to make the most of
your learning time on official sat
practice
research has shown that more time spent
on official sat practice is associated
with greater sat scores
but how you spend that time really
matters
before we begin let's make sure you know
how to access official sat practice
make sure you're signed into your khan
academy account by checking for your
name in the upper right hand corner
if you're using official sct practice in
a class you should see a tab that says
sat on the left side navigation
select the sat tab
from there select practice to be taken
to your student dashboard
if you aren't using sat practice in a
class you can select edit courses to add
the sat tab to your khan academy account
number one
link your account to college board
to receive a personalized practice plan
you have two options
number one take a series of diagnostic
quizzes
or number two
link your college board account to khan
academy
the easiest way to get a study plan that
is personalized to your results is to
link your con and college board accounts
once your accounts are linked we'll
automatically recommend skills where you
have room to improve
especially ones that show up frequently
on the sat
we recommend that you link your accounts
so you can waste no time improving the
right skills
number two
follow your personalized practice
recommendations if you have already
linked your khan academy in college
board accounts you will see your skill
recommendations on the practice tab
at the top of the page you should see a
set of recommended practice for math and
reading and writing that always end in a
timed mini section
now let's take a deeper look at how
skills are recommended
let's say there are two skills at two
different levels skill a
is at level two
skill b is at level three
you might think it would be more
important to improve skill a
however in some cases we may recommend
that you practice skill b because it
shows up more frequently on the sat
and it proving it to level four would do
more to raise your score
number three
level up skills
in official sat practice you have a
specific skill level for the 41 skills
and math and the 28 skills in reading
and writing
as you answer questions your skill
levels will move up
or down depending on how you do
leveling up your skills shows you that
you are consistently advancing in the
content on the sat and it's a great way
to monitor your progress
you might be wondering
but what if i do if i get stuck on a
skill
it's normal to feel stuck at times when
studying for the sat we've all been
there
but those moments of confusion are also
the times when you have the opportunity
to improve your score the most
push through by using the hints
instructional videos
or ask for help when you're learning a
new skill
as you answer questions on official sat
practice you have access to text
explanations and videos to deepen your
understanding of the content
you can also use the review tab to
review your answers from completed
practice
if you're still stuck reach out to one
of your classmates a teacher or a family
member for support
number four
take a full length practice test
select the full test tab at the top to
access the full length sat practice test
taking a practice test is a crucial step
to ensure you're prepared for a test day
by simulating the real test experience
eight full-length practice tests are
available on official sat practice which
can be taken in one sitting or section
by section over time
the information from your full-length
test will also result in even more
personalized practice
now that you know the top four tips to
using official sat practice you're ready
to get started
log in to your khan academy account
today happy studying